I've done quite a bit of research into
the PR tactics the sugar industry has
employed basically to downplay the link
between sugar and heart disease and
instead shift the blame to fat as the
culprit for heart disease and there is
now a new report that has released some
historical documents which date back to
the 1960s going all the way back to the
1960s the sugar industry has been
proactively trying to spin
misinformation around the connection
between sugar consumption and health and
it basically goes two different ways one
way that the sugar industry has been
able to do this is by funding studies
that ended up showing that heart disease
is linked to saturated fat so then the
focus becomes on low-fat diets and very
often when people change one element of
their diet it's relatively zero-sum and
a very easy way to get more calories
when you stop getting as many calories
from fat is to get more calories from
sugar the other way that the sugar
industry has done this and there's a
documentary which I recommended whose
name escapes me now but it's something
like is it sweet dreams I don't remember
but in any case it explores how the
sugar industry anytime an independent
study came out during the 60s 70s 80s
whenever saying sugar consumption is
being linked to a whole bunch of
different conditions and this can be
connected to pre-diabetes pre-diabetic
conditions and so many other things the
sugar industry would fund a study of its
own and they would never straight-up lie
and say there's no connection whatsoever
between consuming tons of sugar and
health effects negative health effects
but they would basically say it's
inconclusive and what it seems like is
you just generally want to control your
total calorie intake and this is the
idea that a calorie is a calorie whether
you get a calorie from sugar or whether
you get a calorie from whatever else
that as long as you're not eating too
many calories your health is going to be
unimpacted by what types of calories
you're getting now we
know that this is absolutely not true
and we can sort of think about this
conceptually by thinking if you look at
the calories that are in a spoonful of
sugar and I don't remember exactly what
number that is if you consider the
calories in a spoonful of sugar and the
amount of some other food you would have
to eat to get that number of calories
and in fact a good comparison would be
something like chicken breast or chicken
thigh you will be much more satisfied or
feeling full if you had that same number
of calories of chicken than if you
consume those calories as a spoonful of
sugar and this really goes to the heart
of the issue right that sugar is these
empty calories sugar is often used in
the form of high fructose corn syrup as
a filler we know corn is very very
heavily subsidized it's a really really
big racket and we now know that for 50
years the sugar industry has been
funding pseudoscience non science and
trying to shift the blame of the
connection between food and heart
disease off of sugar and to fat it's not
really a surprise I mean we've seen this
documented pretty well for a while this
does reveal some particular historical
records that are really really specific
and what what's really disturbing and
this is also revealed in that
documentary the name of which I just
cannot remember right now but it's very
very good it's on Netflix a Harvard
scientists were paid by the sugar
industry to do studies and again they
came out with very shockingly they're
just not able to say that there's any of
negative health repercussions of sugar
and we should all be aware of this we're
increasingly learning much more about
the fact that while we want to avoid
trans fats eating healthy fats is not
the worst thing for for for humans and
we're not talking about the Atkins diet
which does seem to have a fair share of
problems about just going all crazy and
saying my my my food intake is going to
be bacon and just a very processed meats
but that fat in and of itself is not as
big a problem as we thought
salt while you don't want to over
indulgence salt particularly if you have
a predisposition to high blood pressure
salt is not as bad as we were being told
it was for a long time but sugar refined
sugar really really is a major problem
so good that there's a major study about
this now that has revealed the the
specific and deliberate misinformation
campaign